this end i have my idea  look at this he he can hardly hold  himself back yeah he's about to move  yeah and that that kind of nodding  generally indicates somebody who thinks  he's doing well yeah you're you don't  not here if you just play roxy one and  then they take a draw  um  like if he finds all this and doesn't  find rook d2 it's a bit it's a bit weird  because rookie two i would i would think  that rook d2 was simpler than this  but looks like he actually sees rookie  one yeah there it is there it is  it's just amazing stuff  these guys yeah i mean  you know the here he got fooled yeah  because if he would have not been such a  genius spotting rookie one he would have  spotted luke d2 queen c3 yeah  yeah  because simply his attention was carried  away to this line yeah calculating all